[Music]
how does your organization address
racial equity and access to healthcare
delivery for decades researchers have
studied the differences in quality of
care between people of color and their
white counterparts they lead to poor
health outcomes and exemplify low-value
Health Care together with the disparity
Solution Center at Massachusetts General
Hospital this course uses case studies
and insights from leaders so you can
create strategic approaches that you can
apply to your organization the history
is the reason for the disparities
there's no other reason for the
disparities other than our American
history there can be this sense that
we're doing everything right so all of
disparity is somewhere out there but we
need to be really honest with ourselves
when it's at home and a really important
part of implementing any policy or
action at your organization or
Healthcare facility is understanding
that it's a process that doesn't happen
overnight it's a systemic and structural
racism that has existed for all of these
years that has created these significant
disparities that we continue to deal
with today to really Drive
organizational change we have to include
people from the top of our organization
all the way to the bottom learn how to
lead your Healthcare organization and
tackling these systemic problems and
improving patient Equity with reducing
racial disparities in health care
[Music]